una inusual irrupción de la policía
israelí en la mezquita de al-aqsa
alimenta a las tensiones en el segundo
viernes de ramadán que coincide con el
inicio del pesaj judío efectivos
israelíes ingresaron en el tercer sitio
sagrado musulmán luego de las oraciones
matutinas con el argumento de dispersar
a un grupo de palestinos identificados
con banderas de hamas y la autoridad
palestina gases lacrimógenos y balas de
goma fueron respuesta al lanzamiento de
piedras y de fuegos artificiales de
estos manifestantes según la media luna
roja palestina al menos 150 personas
resultaron heridas y las autoridades
informaron de cientos de detenidos esto
ocurre cuando el gobierno israelí ha
endurecido el cerco sobre los
territorios palestinos luego de dos o
cuatro atentados en tres semanas o dos
de ellos perpetrados por palestinos que
dejaron al menos 14 muertos las redadas
y las operaciones policiales israelíes
han ocasionado la muerte de 15
palestinos de al menos 15 palestinos en
2 semanas 6 entre el miércoles y el
jueves
la irrupción fue condenada por la
autoridad palestina que pidió evitar que
las cosas se salgan de control y por
hamas que advirtió a israel de posibles
consecuencias también genera un nuevo en
el debilitado gobierno israelí manzur a
más líder del partido islamista a rami
inédito integrante de la coalición
alertó que un daño continuado en al aqsa
sería una línea roja para la estabilidad
de la alianza el temor a una escalada
mayor de se mantiene con la coincidencia
del ramadán y del pesar lo que llevó a
extremistas judíos a amenazar con la
realización de sacrificios en la
explanada de las mezquitas o monte del
templo considerado por los judíos sobre
como su lugar más sagrado